-Let's get to the news.
President Trump, this weekend,
refused to attend a ceremony
in France honoring American
lives lost in World War I,
due to bad weather.
So, wait a minute.
When you left your umbrella
outside of Air Force One,
that was your only umbrella?
I'm a talk-show host.
I have two umbrellas.
Hope you brought
a second phone charger.
Yesterday was Veterans Day.
"Thank you for your service,"
said Trump to Colonel Sanders.
[ As Trump ]
He fought so many chicken.
[ Normal voice ] Florida
has ordered a mandatory recount
of both its Senate
and gubernatorial results
from last week's election,
and hopefully,
if all goes well with the
Florida recount, by next week,
Al Gore will be president.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ As Gore ]
I was patiently waiting.
I knew this day would come.
[ Normal voice ]
Following the midterm elections,
Republicans will hold leadership
elections this Wednesday,
and current House Majority
Leader Kevin McCarthy
is expected to
become House Minority Leader.
It's tough to find
someone to fill the job,
because no one in
the Republican Party
wants to have the word
"minority" in their title.
[ Laughter ]
In her upcoming memoir,
"Becoming,"
former First Lady
Michelle Obama reveals
that she stopped even
trying to smile
during President Trump's
inaugura--
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was like driving in a car
that just was out of gas.
[ Laughs ]
A ghost took my voice.
In her upcoming memoir,
"Becoming,"
former First Lady
Michelle Obama reveals
that she stopped even
trying to smile
during President Trump's
inauguration,
while First Lady Melania Trump
stopped in the early '90s.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"I don't like the Spin Doctors."
President Trump
and First Lady Melania
attended a
ceremony last week to welcome
Justice Brett Kavanaugh
to the Supreme Court.
No word on what time
the ceremony was held,
but I'm guessing Miller Time?
The official Twitter
account for Fox News
has not posted
a message since last Thursday.
Meanwhile,
the unofficial Twitter account
for Fox News
has posted like 1,000.
A woman in England
has gained media attention
after she revealed that she
breast-fed her daughter
until she was 9 years old.
Well, at least she
didn't have to worry about
her classmates
wanting to trade lunches.
"Uh, let's see.
I got a peanut butter and jelly.
What do you -- Oh, my God!"
And, finally, designer brand
Yves Saint Laurent
has released
a new line of jewelry
that features tiny penises.
They would
have made them bigger,
but it's their
winter collection.